Three trends are converging that will create a new cultural landscape in Korea.
The first is Korea's falling birthrate.
The second is the trend toward increased intercultural and interracial marriage in Korea.
This past year alone,...
...fully 13 percent of all marriages were international marriages.
The third is the birth of children of foreign workers and trainees...
...who (contrary to expectation)...
...will not go back to their home country but continue to live and work in Korea.
In the past, it was very easy to discriminate against racially or culturally mixed children...
...whether they were primarily fathered by Japanese from the late 1800s to 1945...
...or by soldiers from UN member countries during the Korean War.
From 1954 they were primarily the result of relationships with U.S. soldiers and local women...
...that unfortunately did not work out.
Perhaps it was easier to discriminate against these children...
...because they are unhappy reminders of extremely unhappy moments in Korean history.
Furthermore, because the mothers of these children...
...were neither economically nor socially powerful,
...it was easy to reject them and discriminate against their rainbow-hued offspring.
But times are changing and one should not have to be Hines Ward just to get a little respect.
The time has now come to embrace all Koreans regardless of skin color...
...by seeing that they are given the equality of opportunity to be successful in education,...
...employment and all other aspects of life.